la cpd par notre portefeuille s'est
payée par l'argent du contribuable vous
l'avait dit et on est sur une campagne
injuste de propagande de ce que sont les
idées développées depuis le début par le
président de la république et c'est pas
ça on a vraiment l'impression que la
honte or ce qui normalement doit être un
clip objectifs destinés à s'adresser aux
français de tous bords et là on voit
très bien le message subliminal
le message subliminal c'est en gros il
ya les gentils et les méchants
levez-vous d'immenses pour voter pour
les gentils vous avez le choix
cette fois-ci vous avez le choix cette
élection c'est pas une élection pour
éliminer c'est une élection pour choisir
et je fais sur cette fin de campagne en
appelle à tous les électeurs de la
droite et du centre à tous les français
qui partagent ces convictions c'est le
moment de vous exprimer c'est le moment
de vous faire entendre
la seule liste qui est capable de porter
cette voie ses convictions de la droite
et du centre c'est à dire quoi d'abord
et on croit dans l'europe
nous on veut une europe qui défend ses
frontières on veut une europe qui
défendent les produits de ces
entreprises
on veut une europe qui affirme son
identité notamment face à l'islamisme
eh bien on est la soliste qui peut
envoyer des députés au parlement
européen qui défendent ses convictions
on a à faire dans cette élection un
choix sur quelle europe on veut au fond
résumons-nous assez simplement vous avez
le choix entre le rassemblement national
c'est la déconstruction de l'europe et
la déconstruction de l'euro de l'autre
côté vous avez le projet qui est porté
par emmanuel macron qu'est ce que c'est
toujours plus de taxes mais l'europe
d'emmanuel macron c'est aussi celle de
l'élargissement et là dessus il ya un
double discours total par rapport à sa
tête de liste à trieste il a dit qu'il
souhaitait l'élargissement aux pays des
balkans l'albanie doit normalement
ouvrir ces négociations et ça a été
acceptée y compris la france n'y a pas
opposé son veto en juin prochain
nous notre ligne est très simple tous
nos députés s'opposeront à tupac irait
dans un élargissement supplémentaire et
on arrête les négociations avec la
turquie parce que la turquie n'est pas
européenne
pour nous il y aura un avant et un après
cette élection parce que qu'est ce qu'on
a réussi à faire
on a réussi à rajeunir on a réussi à
faire émerger des nouveaux talents
on a réussi à rassembler et on a réussi
à montrer que la droite se
reconstruisait en assumant ses valeurs
tout en fédérant c'est évidemment pour
nous une étape très importante et c'est
une étape dans cette reconstruction et
je suis très lucide on n'est pas arrivé
c'est pas fini
les français nous ont pas encore fait
confiance à nouveau il on se doute que
vous avez d'ailleurs verbalisé en disant
est ce qu'ils ont tiré les leçons
est-ce qu'ils ont changé est ce que
c'est vraiment une nouvelle droite
à nous d'être capables de répondre